comedy is also an interesting thing
because sometimes there happens to be
depending on the show on the format
there tends to be parameters do you have
things that are off limits or is there's
things that you're like that's too far
for me to go where I want to stay within
this realm of course but we don't I
wouldn't say that any of those things
are really apparent to me in the moment
do you I don't have a list of 10 things
that I'll never talk about because I
don't think that that's a really fluid
that's a really fluid thing I think
there there are stories that emerge that
are very interesting that we all feel
really strongly about but there's no way
to tell them comedic ly and so we put
those to the back burner and just hope
that one day we can find a framework
within which to tell the story that we
think is important but you know for the
so that happens but I wouldn't say that
there's a distinct list of things then
but that we stay away from on purpose do
you find it interesting that from a
bird's eye view you look at yourself
yoga John Oliver you look at Trevor Noah
that the the you know satirical aspect
of American politics and world issues is
being told by all foreigners well not
well well the three most the three
that's out there giving it all these
great shot you know yeah that's true but
I mean those are three big hitters I
would say I would say it is can be very
helpful it can be very helpful it gives
you you know I do bring it I don't think
that this show is the perfect uses but
when I started at The Daily Show so many
years ago I think of my outside or point
of view was really helpful to me it's
not the same I've been here for too long
now and now I'm a dual citizen so I'm
kind of a part of it now
I feel like you've read of it who are
some of the people you look up to I mean
it's oh I never can answer that question
for sure yeah who do I look at I
mentioned this to so many people I
really do I really do anyway I can't
think of any of their names I'm old but
I feel like there's their shows that you
could aspire to be like like you know
you know you look at Jimmy Fallon and
he's like let him inform II was the
benchmark of the show I want to create
their comfort level a little echo when
si you know
look at someone like louis c.k you know
and i am just such a massive fan of his
and I do you know I've heard him speak
about his process and our process is not
the same we're not doing the same type
of thing really but he's a creator and
his vision is the absolute most
important thing to him and he you know
lets a lot of stuff go in the service of
his vision and I think that he's
provided a lot of inspiration to me
listening to him talking about that
because it is that's what I respond to
as a viewer when you have a vision for
your show when you have a clear point of
view I will watch your show I just need
it to have I need to have someone take
me into a world and he takes me into a
world your kids Wes your show no they
don't they have no interest in watching
my show no they don't watch it it's not
really I don't think they would really
enjoy it who wants to see their mama
romping around a stage and a colorful
blazer that's not fun you have to think
of your mamas someone who makes you
breakfast you still make a breakfast
horse are you kidding we're kicking
mostest
I mean it's so Canadian having them
think of me as a boring nerd is the most
important yeah aspect to early that
keeps the natural order okay as long
they should not think that I do anything
cool